(In Ilnu-aimun: Hello).
I’m Valérie Courtois
and I’m from the Ilnu community
of Mashteuiatsh,
located in Pekuakami or Lac Saint-Jean,
the heart of what is now known as Québec.
It is an honor to be here
with you tonight.
A good friend and colleague of mine,
the Honorable Ethel Blondin-Andrew,
the first Indigenous woman
to be elected to Canada's parliament
and to serve in cabinet,
shared with me some wisdom she received:
“A mark of a good leader
is if they leave a room
filled with more hope
than when they first arrived.”
I'm here with you tonight
to attempt to fulfill that aspiration.
To leave you with hope.
We need it now more than ever.
Our home, our shared beautiful mother,
our planet is experiencing
ecological turmoil.
We humans are transforming it to a point
where we are risking the survival
of millions of species.
And as a result, our societies
are also experiencing a parallel turmoil
as we struggle to adapt
to the unnatural pace
and scale of change.
My homelands, known as Nitassinan,
are also experiencing these changes.
It is a harsh, but strikingly beautiful
part of the boreal forest.
Nitassinan is at its best when it is cold.
Yet, we are seeing extreme changes in ice
and in key species such as caribou.
When I first drove into Labrador
two decades ago,
I had to stop on the
Trans-Labrador Highway for hours
as the George River caribou herd crossed.
There were hundreds
of thousands in the herd then.
Now, there are only 8,000 left.
I've seen firsthand the devastating
impact of climate change
and the loss of biodiversity
in my homeland of Nitassinan
and all across what is now
known as Canada.
But I’ve also seen something else,
something that gives me hope.
It’s not a technology from a lab.
It’s not a policy made in Ottawa or DC.
It is the fundamental understanding
that is expressed by our knowledge,
by our elders and knowledge
keepers this way:
If we take care of the land,
the land takes care of us.
Let me say it again.
If we take care of the land,
the land takes care of us.
This is about a relationship,
a mutual love story.
(Applause)
It's not an accident that 80 percent
of the world's remaining biodiversity
are located on lands managed and loved
by Indigenous peoples.
We have been in relationships
with the plants and animals
of our territories
and waters for millennia.
We care for each other.
The Innu people have loved and sustained
and been in harmony with our landscapes
for nearly 10,000 years.
Surely we have values, insights,
strategies and knowledge to offer
to the rest of the global community
with respect to how to be a part of
and care for our environment.
This knowledge is essential right now.
It can help people and the land heal
from ecological crises and colonization.
It can help restore the planet
and it can help save us all.
By fully respecting and acknowledging
Indigenous-led approaches to the land,
we can help create
a better future for all.
What does it look like?
It looks like Indigenous Guardians.
So, you've heard
of the "Guardians of the Galaxy?"
Well, these guardians are doing a much
more important job right here on Earth,
just without the soundtrack.
(Laughter)
Guardians are trained experts who work
on behalf of their Indigenous nations.
They're our eyes and ears on the land.
They monitor water quality,
care for Indigenous-protected
and conserved areas,
conduct research on climate impacts
and help restore species
like caribou, salmon and moose.
Their work is rooted in Indigenous
and Western sciences
and their training includes
everything from GIS mapping
to spending time with elders
and knowledge keepers.
We need this now more than ever.
Guardians also do something more personal.
Time and again,
I've heard people say that being
a guardian has changed their lives.
I think of the young Jarett Quock,
a young man from the Tahltan First Nation
in what is now known as British Columbia.
Jarett used to be
a heavy-equipment operator
working on job sites
far from his community.
He faced racism
from non-Indigenous peoples
and non-unrelated,
unfortunately, he struggled
with addictions.
So when a job opened up
with a Tahltan Wildlife Guardians,
he decided to take it.
He said,
"Being a guardian helped get me
through the tough times in my life.
Being connected to the land
and talking with elders
helped me overcome my addictions.
It brought pride to me.
And at the end of the day,
I could walk away with the pride
of being First Nations."
(Applause)
I know what he means.
As a person who's been a witness to
and felt the intergenerational trauma
from the colonial experience
and the horrors of residential
schools or institutions,
where Indigenous children were forcibly
removed from their homes
and sent to so-called "schools"
to be indoctrinated
into the dominant Canadian society,
I've found no better strategy to healing
than nurturing our
relationship with our place.
I've seen the healing powers
of the land in action countless times.
The land heals
and I wish that experience for anyone
who has experienced and lives with trauma.
Ethel Blondin-Andrew,
the leader I mentioned before,
runs training camps for guardians
in the Northwest Territories.
She says,
"Residential schools cause great grief
and intergenerational trauma
because they taught us
that we are not worthy of love."
But we are worthy of love.
The kids in our camps get it.
They know that being on the land
is where they are the best human beings
that they can be.
Researchers have documented
the impacts of guardian programs.
They can reduce incarceration
and increase health and well-being.
People's health improves on the land
because they're on the land,
because they're physically active
and because they're happy.
And guardians gained increased skills,
higher incomes and pride
in cultural knowledge.
In fact, one study in 2016 documented
the impacts of those guardian programs
and showed that for every dollar invested,
there's a return on that investment
of 2.5 dollars in social, economic
and environmental benefits.
With sustained funding,
that return on investment
jumps to almost four dollars.
That's why that I believe that Indigenous
programs could do more for healing
from the impacts of colonialism
than any other individual program.
Guardians help honor
our responsibility of the land
and they can create
a better future for all.
Because guardianship
isn't just good for guardians,
it's good for everyone
because the land
is taking care of guardians
and guardians are taking care of the land.
Guardians help care
for some of the healthiest,
most vibrant lands on the continent.
Many work in the boreal forest
which stretches from Alaska
to Newfoundland.
It is one of the largest intact
forests left on the planet.
Having guardians on the ground
will help us sustain so many species
like caribou, salmon, moose,
wolverine, lynx, songbirds,
medicinal plants
and countless other species --
species that are unfortunately threatened
in much of the rest of the world.
They also help protect some
of the largest protected areas
on the planet.
You may not know this,
but some of the biggest, most ambitious
plans to protect areas in Canada
are led by Indigenous peoples.
(Applause)
Many of them, they're creating Indigenous
protected and conserved areas.
These areas that they create based
on their own laws and cultures
and often in partnerships
with Crown governments,
or Canadian governments,
for the Americans in the room.
You know, in fact,
three of these areas alone
in the Northwest Territories
span 50,000 square kilometers in size.
That's about the size of Costa Rica.
The Kaska Dena
in northern British Columbia
are planning to create
a protected area the size of Switzerland.
And in northern Manitoba,
four Dene and Cree nations
are coming together
to protect the Seal River Watershed,
home to caribou, belugas, polar bears
and thousands of songbirds.
It will be nearly five times the size
of Yellowstone National Park.
(Applause)
There are dozens of protected areas
in the works right now,
right across Canada.
Many of them will protect some
of the largest carbon storehouses
of any terrestrial ecosystem
on the planet.
Remember when I said that my homeland
is at its best when it was cold?
Well, its ability to capture
and store carbon over centuries
is insured by that cold,
because when organic matter
and litter fall to the ground,
it decomposes extremely slowly
in its very deep soils.
In fact, the boreal forest holds
twice as much carbon
as the world's tropical
forests per hectare.
(Applause)
Yeah, go boreal!
(Laughter)
This is why I'm here.
That protected area in the Seal River
Watershed I mentioned,
it holds 1.7 billion tons of carbon
equivalent to eight years’ worth
of greenhouse-gas emissions alone --
in Canada alone.
Protecting the watershed will help
keep that carbon in place.
These are the kind of lands
that guardians are caring for.
They also help heal and restore places.
The Innu guardians, for example,
they help care for and monitor
the largest nickel mine in the world
at Voisey's Bay in Labrador.
Guardians help ensure
that when development occurs,
it happens with the informed
consent of our nations.
That projects do not have an adverse
effect on our rights and titles.
And that our nations and communities
can benefit or maximize those benefits
from those development activities.
Whether they are monitoring
the largest nickel mine in the world
or sustaining giant carbon storehouses,
guardians are helping honor
our responsibility to the land.
And the benefits,
they ripple far and wide.
As Gloria Enzo, a Ni Hat’Ni Dene guardian
from the Northwest Territory says,
"We are sustaining
our traditional territories
not only for us,
but for the whole world."
By honoring and respecting
Indigenous-led approaches to the land,
we can create a better future for all.
You know, there's a role
for everyone in this model.
Every person, family, community, nation
is essential to dealing with the crises
that we're facing as peoples
and as a planet.
All actions, big and small,
that contribute to addressing
these challenges
will help us get closer to that goal.
In fact,
I'd like to ask you to join
Indigenous peoples
in helping protect and create
a better future,
one where we are ensuring
our collective futures
as peoples on this planet.
There is so much that we can do together.
Specifically,
study the history of Indigenous nations
with traditional territories
in the places where you live and work.
Talk with non-Indigenous friends
about Indigenous leadership on the land.
Create space for Indigenous
voices and uplift them.
Hold up our communities
and respect our knowledge systems.
Make sure that you are using
your political voices
and voting for leaders
who support this vision,
because Indigenous guardians can ensure
that we all have the future on this planet
that we deserve and want,
so that we can all continue to have
an evolving love story
with our lands, with our waters
that we call home.
We can all heal the planet
by drawing on the knowledge
of our ancestors
and blending them with the best tools
of the modern world.
If we take care of the land,
the land will take care of us forever.
(In Ilnu-aimun: Thank you).
(Applause)